Ich bin ein Kumpel von Kumpel.
Ich bin ein Kumpel von Kumpel. Ich bin ein Kumpel von Kumpel.
Die zwei Sprechstunden.
Letzter Mittwoch im Monat, Chaosradio Teil 132, Erdgeist Frank Constanze sind hier, mein Name ist Jakob Kranz, wir reden über das heutige Urteil vom Bundesverfassungsgericht, dass die Online-Durchsuchung und der sogenannte Bundestrojaner in der Form, wie sie gerne gewollt würden, so nicht durchsetzbar sind, sondern dass ein konkreter Verdacht auf eine konkrete Bedrohung bestehen muss, um diese Mittel einzusetzen. Das heißt, wie wir es eben in der ersten Stunde schon erwähnt haben, dass die Hürde, diese Mittel einzusetzen, so dermaßen hoch ist, wie sie eigentlich auch von den Leuten, die sie haben wollten, formuliert wurde, dass es heute durchaus als ein guter Tag in Sachen Datensicherung und Datenschutz dleichend werden kann. Stimmt's? Stimmt's. Und damit schninken wir rüber zu Frank. Hallo, Frank. Du musstest jetzt lange warten, aber hier am Telefon ist gerade die Hölle los. Alle Leute freuen sich oder regen sich total auf und wollen sich hier im Ärger Luft machen. Du bist der nächste. Freust du dich oder ärgerst du dich drüber? Das ist schön.
Und im Endeffekt ist es auch so, das hab ich jetzt irgendwo gelesen, der Computer und alles, was damit zusammen hängt, wird zum Teil der Persönlichkeit erklärt. Und das passt eben zu dem, was eben gesagt hat, die digitale Welt war richtig mehr mobilisiert worden. Und die Richter sind da eben drauf eingegangen und haben eben den Computers zu einem wichtigen Teil meiner Persönlichkeit erklärt. Das find ich gut so.
Bist du jemand, der mit dem Computer auf du und du ist? Also der klingt total nach 1985, aber der schon irgendwie mit dem Rechner lebt und ein Leben ohne Rechner sich nicht vorstellen kann?
Ich kann mir das so ohne Rechner nicht mehr vorstellen. Ich hab das eigentlich seit kleinem angefangen mit damals dem VC20. Und das war eigentlich noch nie anders.
Wo kommst du denn her, Frank?
Aus Leichlingen. Das liegt in Nordrhein-Westfalen.
Oh, bei der Wurzel alles Bösen.
Ja, genau.
Du wirst also in dem Land, wo der Verfassungsschutz dich hätte ausspionieren können.
Theoretisch ja. Wobei, ich finde es jetzt gut, dass die hohen Auflagen da, dass das Gesetz hat, solches jetzt mal so gekippt worden ist. Und das ist immer eine gute Sache. Und die Auflagen, die so hoch sind, sind auch eigentlich ganz positiv. Also ich finde das ganz gut. Ich habe nur die Befürchtung, dass so ein Herrn Schäuble irgendwie wieder so ein Quasi-Verteidigungsfall oder so was einfallen wird, indem man versucht, das wieder auszuhebeln. Und das müsste dann wieder von Verfassungsgericht geklärt werden, dass es eben nicht geht, so wie damals mit den Flugzeugen die Sache da.
Beim Luftsicherheitsgesetz.
Ja, genau, und ich meine, der gute Mann ist sehr kreativ und so was, finde ich. Und da hätte man vielleicht noch klarer machen können, dass das für den Mann, also vom Verfassungsgericht her klarer machen können, dass das für den Mann eine ohrfeige gewesen ist und dass er eben nicht frei hantieren kann, so wie er es mit dem Luftsicherheitsgesetz probiert hat.
Formal ist er natürlich nicht zuständig. Es war ja eigentlich jetzt so, dass der Innenminister von Nordrhein-Westfalen FDP-Mann ist und einer der Kläger ebenfalls, also der ehemalige Bundesminister Gerhard Baum. Genau, da hat ja eigentlich jetzt der Schäuble direkt nichts damit zu tun. Aber es geht natürlich im Hintergrund auch immer darum, dass ja in wenigen Wochen schon der BKA-Gesetzentwurf ins Kabinett gebracht werden soll, dass also darüber entschieden wird, ob auch eben Polizeibehörden online durchsuchen können. Und hier haben sich die Richter auch sehr klar darauf bezogen. Sie haben also gesagt, es geht hier nicht um Geheimdienste nur, sondern es geht auch um die Polizei.
Und da kommen wir jetzt, Frank Wadermeyer. Ich würde ganz kurz Alex mit Ihnen in die Leitung nehmen, der sich ein bisschen vordringelt, aber das passt hervorragend rein. Name ist Alex. Du rufst aus Magdeburg an. Du willst wissen, wie eine Online-Durchsuchung eigentlich abläuft.
Ja, ich hätte halt schon gern gewusst, ob da jetzt konkret einer in seinem Rechner sitzt und dann guckt, was irgendwer anders macht. Oder ob da jetzt auch irgendwie Software-Tools eingesetzt werden, die...
Na, die eigentliche Idee war ja quasi, einen Trojaner per E-Mail zu verschicken. Und dann steht als Absender nicht drauf, mit freundlichen Grüßen dein Bundesinnenministerium, sondern steht irgendwie drauf, ihre Zulassungsstelle oder Steueramt oder so.
Also die tatsächliche technische Durchführung, wie schon erwähnt, wie die denn tatsächlich aussieht, also ob es eine Hardware-Manipulation ist oder ob es eine Software-Manipulation ist oder ob du eine CD kriegst oder sie den Trojaner per Hand installieren oder eine E-Mail ist, die ist tatsächlich offen gelassen. Also es ist nicht so, dass aus diesem Urteil irgendeine Art von Beschränkung des technischen Mittels folgt, sondern es wird nur eine Reihe von technischen Mitteln ausdrücklich erwähnt, zum Beispiel auch elektronische Abstrahlung, also tatsächlich die Belauschung des Monitors. Genau, Keylogger. Dass die halt auch explizit unter diese hohen Schranken fallen. Das heißt also, das Gericht hat halt nicht gesagt, also diese Technologie dürfte er verwenden, diese Technologie dürfte er nicht verwenden, sondern sie hat gesagt, de facto alles, was dazu führt, dass dein Rechner ausgespäht werden kann, fällt unter diese hohen Schranken. Da bleibt sozusagen der Fantasie des BKA überlassen, was sie jetzt genau anwenden.
Da wo ich eigentlich drauf hinaus will, ist eigentlich, wenn wir jetzt von größeren Datenmengen reden, die sie ja auch durchsuchen wollen, mit irgendwelchen Data-Mining-Techniken oder was weiß ich, dann setzen wir ja irgendwelche Software ein. Und das Problem, das ich habe, ist, dass viele Leute, die jetzt auch sagen, sie hätten jetzt nichts zu verbergen, irgendwie anscheinend ein riesengroßes Vertrauen daran haben, dass diese Tools, die da eingesetzt werden, einfach 100% korrekt funktionieren. Und ich finde eigentlich jeder, der selber schon mal irgendwie mit Software zu tun hat oder so...
Erdgeist hat das ja gerade sehr schön formuliert.
Ja, also de facto ist es halt so, dass genau dieser Risikoaspekt ist, den das Verfassungsgericht auch erwähnt hat, dass sie gesagt haben, der Einsatz dieses Werkzeugs ist halt mit hohen Risiken verbunden, egal welche Technologie jetzt verwendet wird, also vielleicht mal mit der Ausnahme von kompromittierenden Emissionen, also elektronischen Abstrahlung, gibt es halt immer die Gefahr, dass das System beeinträchtigt wird und dass halt Kollateralschäden entstehen. Und auch deswegen, das ist einer der Gründe, werden halt die Schranken so hochgelegt.
Wir haben uns eigentlich auch sehr gefreut, dass die Richter einen gewissen Interessenkonflikt explizit erwähnt haben, der daran besteht, dass er zum einen der Ziel der Bundesregierung ist, die Rechner zu sichern, jetzt mal zum Beispiel für die Wirtschaft, dass wir eben möglichst sichere Rechner haben. Und aber auf der anderen Seite eben versuchen wir, Sicherheitslücken auszunutzen für die Ausspionierung. Also diesen Interessenkonflikt, den haben die Richter auch explizit angesprochen.
Das ist sowieso eine Sache, die ich sowieso nicht verstehe, weil teilweise das BSI oder so, die geben wirklich konkrete Tipps auf, wie man seinen Rechner eigentlich absichern soll.
Genau.
Und auf der anderen Seite scheinen andere Bundesminister, die scheinen ja überhaupt nicht miteinander zu sprechen.
Das war ja auch wohl Absicht. Der BSI wurde aus der Sache mal rausgehalten.
Für die Hobbyköcher unter uns, BSI ist das?
Das Bundesamt für Sicherheit in der Informationstechnik.
Das Bundesamt, was halt tatsächlich dafür zuständig ist.
Die Zentralstelle für Schöprierweg.
Die geben so CDs raus, auf denen so die Standard-Viren-Scan-Tools umsonst drauf sind und PGP.
Na ja, sie machen halt noch ein bisschen mehr. Die sind halt de facto dafür zuständig, die Bundesbehörden abzusichern, also tatsächlich die Informationstechnik der Bundesbehörden zu sichern. Und betreiben halt auch in größerem Umfang IT-Sicherheitsmaßnahmen, Projekte usw. und so fort. Und da war natürlich von Anfang an klar, dass es da einen Interessenkonflikt gibt. Denen haben sie halt versucht, dadurch zu entschärfen, dass sie das BSI halt da rausgehalten haben. Die sagten, okay, das macht das BKA, das Bundeskriminalamt. Und das BSI bleibt da mal außen vor.
Aber es kann trotzdem immer mal gucken, ob der Virenscanner beim BKA aktuell ist.
Zumal halt das BSI wahrscheinlich am meisten darüber weiß, was gerade an Lücken im Umlauf ist, mit denen halt so ein Eindringen möglich wäre. Insofern, naja, da bleibt halt immer ein Geschmäckle dabei. Und insofern haben die Richter halt auch diesen Interessenkonflikt nochmal explizit betont.
Alex, ich hoffe, die Frage nach der Online-Durchsuchung ist damit beantwortet.
Ja, nee, also finde ich auch sehr gut, dass die, dass wir auch vom Bundesverfassungsgericht auch wirklich darauf eingegangen sind, dass da halt eben nicht dieses Vertrauen in diese Software einfach so da sein kann, weil es halt ein technisches System ist, was per se fehlerbehaftet sein kann.
Na ja, dass es halt nicht immer so funktioniert, wie sie sich das vorstellen. Hat man euch auch gesehen, als die Bundesregierung selber Ziel der Online-Durchsuchung aus China geworden ist. Auch da haben sie es ja am Ende rausgefunden. Und genauso kann man sich vorstellen, dass auch der Bundestrojaner dann entdeckt werden würde. Und dann, wenn Dritte Kenntnis davon erlangen, wie dieser Bundestrojaner funktioniert, dann werden sie natürlich dieselben Sicherheitslücken, über die der Trojaner eingedrungen ist, selber benutzen können oder sogar noch Fehler im Bundestrojaner finden und den benutzen zu eigenen Zwecken.
Tschüss.
So Frank, wir mussten Alex mal kurz dazwischen schieben, weil die Frage jetzt explizit technisch im Raum stand. Können wir dir noch irgendwie weiterhelfen?
Ja, zwar eben, sante der vorige Anrufer irgendwas, wegen dass keine Konsequenzen aus den Sachen folgen, wurden politisch gesehen. Ich lese jetzt hier gerade, da ist eine grüne Innexpertin, Düker heißt die, die nannte das Urteil die höchstrichtliche Bestätigung für den Verrat von Grundrechten durch den FDP Innenminister Wolfgang Wolf. Zudem eine fachliche und handwerkliche Inkompetenz. Da bliebe eben nur noch eine Konsequenz, der Rücktritt. Das ist ja nur schon mal der Ansatz, dass da politisch auch was passieren könnte, wenn die ständig mitkommen. Irgendwann muss es immer eine für die Nuss geben.
Da wird halt ein Internet-Ausdrucker durch einen anderen Internet-Ausdrucker ersetzt.
Der Punkt ist, wenn alle Minister, die so ein Gerichtsurteil zu verantworten haben, also die das Gesetz geschrieben haben, jedes Mal zurücktreten müssen, dann hätten wir echt ein Karussell an Rücktritten. Weil es sind ja nur wirklich schon eine ganze Latte angesetzt.
Man sollte vielleicht in dem Zusammenhang nicht vergessen, dass auch gerade Landtagswahlen quer durch die Bundesrepublik ziehen und dass da auch so ein bisschen parteipolitisches Karten-Gemische dazugehört.
Das liegt einfach daran, dass das ein bisschen ja, geplänkelt ist von den Wahlen.
Ich weiß nicht, also das ist... Kann man durchaus als Nuance mit einfließen lassen.
Also Verrat von Grundrechten, das ist schon heftig.
Man muss das wohl so nennen. Also ich meine, die Richter waren ja da sehr deutlich. Das ist halt nichtig und zwar aus mehr als einem Grund. Also sie haben die Verfassung hier schon missachtet.
Genau, und das ist also für einen Innenminister, der die Verfassung eigentlich achten soll, zwar die NRW-Verfassung, aber ist das eigentlich ein Rücktrittsgrund. Sehe ich es wirklich so.
Wir hätten nichts dagegen.
Und dann wünsche ich euch noch einen schönen Abend.
Wir sollten jetzt mal ganz kurz eine Musik spielen, auch mit besonderen Grüßen an den Rest vom CTC, nämlich an Tim, der ein Stück Musik ausgesucht hat, was in dieser Sendung heute laufen soll. Es kommt von Die Computers. Ich bin gespannt.
Ich bin ja aber......schlecht drauf.
Das ist ja gleich zu Ende. Wenn es ein Essen wäre, könnte man sagen, gut, das muss man auch mal gekostet haben.
An dieser Stelle danke an Tim.
Danke an Tim, aber wir wollen bei der Gelegenheit vielleicht noch auf den Chaosradio Express hinweisen, denn in der nächsten Zeit gab es wirklich tolle Sendungen, insbesondere die zu Hubschraubern und die zu World of Warcraft. Also wer Lust hat, kann sich die als Podcast holen und wir wollen auch darauf verweisen, dass der Chaos Computer Club demnächst mit seiner wirklich sehr bemerkenswerten Zeitschrift da Tinschleude rauskommt.
So viel zum Thema Eigenwerbung. Sie hörten in der Werbesendung Chaosradio 132. Frank, Erdgeist, Konstanze und Jakob sind hier bei Fritz. Ihr könnt anrufen 0331 77 97 110. Wir reden über den heutigen Beschluss vom Bundesverfassungsgericht, die gesagt haben, Online-Durchsuchung, my ass, baby. Im weitesten Sinne. Am Telefon ist Andi.
Hallo Andi. Hallo Welt, ja.
Hallo Welt, war ein super Stück Musik, oder?
Der Wahnsinn.
Der Wahnsinn. Ich glaube, es war eher das Wahnsinn. Aber das ist ja in dem Fall auch egal. Andi, was hast du beizutragen zu unserer Lust und Ohne?
Ich wollte eigentlich nur meine unglaubliche Erleichterung über das heutige Urteil zum Ausdruck bringen. Und ich erhoffe mir eigentlich auch jede Menge Signalwirkung für die ganze restliche Überwachungsscheiße, die gerade so läuft.
Das hatten wir ja vorhin schon kurz erwähnt und zur Kenntnis gegeben, dass auch die Richter heute das Wort Vorratsdatenspeicherung äußerst kritisch formuliert haben.
Du hattest gesagt, du hast mal eine gebrauchte Festplatte gekauft?
Ja, richtig, habe ich mal gemacht.
Was war denn da drauf?
Habe ich nicht weiter geschaut. Also ich hatte mal stapelalte Festplatten gekauft, wo teilweise noch Herstellergarantie drauf war und die waren eigentlich als defekt deklariert. Und als ich die nacheinander bei mir angestöpselt habe, habe ich gemerkt, dass auf der einen noch ein Dateisystem drauf war. Die war halt nicht mal formatiert und habe halt da irgendwie eine Verzeichnisstruktur gesehen, habe da gar nicht weiter, habe dann aber nicht weiter durchsucht oder so, dann habe die dann gleich mit hier binären Zufallszahlen überschrieben, bevor ich sie dann zum Hersteller geschickt habe.
Nicht ein kleines Fitzelchen Neugier in dir?
Nee, das hat mich auch überhaupt nicht interessiert, weil ich ehrlich gesagt ja schon perplex war, dass da jemand irgendwie bei einem Computerlager, wo ich das gekauft habe, seine Festplatte irgendwie abgibt, ohne die vorher so formatiert wenigstens zu vertieren.
Das ist so ein bisschen wie die EC-Karte liegen lassen, die Nummer drauf schreiben.
Zum Thema Festplatten, da gibt es ja gerade diesen massiven Skandal in Hongkong, in China, Entschuldigung. Wo ein großer Schauspieler, also der sehr bekannteste Lokal, hat halt seinen Computer zum Reparieren gegeben. Und da waren halt noch lauter Bilder von seinen weiblichen Eroberungen drauf. Und die halt dann von dem Techniker da geborgen und irgendwie in die Inhalt gepumpt wurden, was jetzt halt zu einem unglaublichen Skandal führt. Zum Beispiel, dass eine dieser Schauspielerinnen, die da irgendwie beteiligt war, halt jetzt nicht mehr die Öffnung von der Olympiade machen darf, weil sie halt in diesen Skandal verwickelt sind und so weiter, also in China wird gerade auch in großem Umfang Sensibilisierung für private Daten auf privaten Computern betrieben. Das ist halt ein Klassiker. Also es findet immer wieder statt, dass Leute halt ihre Daten nicht schützen, wenn sie ihre Computer zur Reparatur geben. Und naja, man kann sich überlegen, was da für Leute arbeiten heutzutage so bei Computer-Reparatur betrieben. Die sind dann halt im Zweifel auch neugierig.
Ja, da kommt eigentlich noch eine andere Problematik dazu, denn es ist tatsächlich auch so, dass in Deutschland die Ermittlungsbehörden immer mehr auszuwertende Festplatten an Privatfirmen weitergeben. Das heißt, dass man sich nicht mehr unbedingt darauf verlassen kann, wenn man schon beschlagnahmte Festplatte irgendwie abgeben muss, dass der Staat die auswertet, sondern die werden einfach an dritte Dienstleister gegeben. Auch hier ist natürlich nach dem heutigen Urteil doch hoffentlich eine Änderung dieser Praxis zu erwarten.
Ja, also die Landeskriminalämter saufen halt den Festplatten, weil halt bei jeder Hausbesuchung werden halt computer mitgenommen. Also praktisch jeder.
Ich lasse meine alten Festplatten auch immer gleich mitnehmen von den Beamten.
Ich habe vielleicht da noch eine Frage zu den Festplatten bei den Ermittlungsbehörden. Und zwar sind ja irgendwie alle meine Festplatten habe ich AES verschlüsselt mit lang langen Passwörtern. Und es würde mich interessieren, was die Ermittlungsbehörden da machen können, um die trotzdem zu knacken.
Sie gucken sich natürlich an, was noch außerhalb des Kryptosystems ist und typischerweise gucken sie halt danach, was halt an Passwortresten möglicherweise noch im Swap-File ist und so weiter. Auch da haben heute die Verfassungsrichter ein sehr interessantes Statement zu abgegeben. Sie haben nämlich gesagt, dass die Verschlüsselung von Daten tatsächlich ein informationeller Selbstschutz ist, der ein Recht ist. Das heißt also, das kann tatsächlich, also das Ab- Umgehen dieses informationellen Selbstschutzes stellt wiederum einen schweren Grundrechtseingriff dar. Also sprich, wenn sie dir einen Trojaner installieren, um an deine verschlüsselten Daten zu kommen, ist es nochmal tatsächlich ein wesentlich schwerer Grundrechtseingriff, als wenn sie dir nur deine Festplatte beschlagnahmen würden, weil du versuchst, dir aktiv Dinge zu verbargen. Und sie haben halt definiert, dass es dein Recht ist, weil du tatsächlich in dieser Welt heutzutage davon ausgehen musst, dass deine Platte irgendwann mal verloren geht, dein Laptop geklaut wird oder so. Und dass du halt entsprechende Vorkehrungen triffst und du auch davon ausgehen können musst, dass dir auch Gegengangsbehörden helfen.
Was im Zusammenhang mit der Vorratsdatenspeicherung, die wir vorhin ja schon mal angesprochen haben, wie ich finde, ein weiterer, höchst interessanter Punkt ist, in diesem ganzen großen, großen Urteil, dass Karlsruhe sagt, die Verschlüsselung von Daten und damit die Wahrung meiner eigenen Privatsphäre ist mein Recht. Und nicht wie es früher war, wenn ich meine Daten verschlüsselte oder aber mich darum kümmere, dass keine anderen Leute an meine Daten rankommen, mache ich mich möglicherweise verdächtig, weil ich hätte ja vielleicht etwas zu verbergen. Das finde ich ist ein ganz interessanter Dreh an der ganzen Geschichte. Das erklärt vielleicht auch die Dimension dieses Urteils, was heute passiert ist.
Genau dieser Punkt, dass Verschlüsselung nicht mehr verdächtig ist, ist auch tatsächlich einer der großen Pluspunkte dieses Urteils.
Damit sind wir jetzt einfach auch in eine neue Zeit übergegangen, mit diesem Grundrecht. Denn bei all der Wirtschaftskriminalität und den vielen Spionage-Software-Tools, wenn auch sehr einfacher, die man so aus dem Netz sich einfallen kann, mit seinem normalen Windows-Betriebssystem, müssen wir einfach davon ausgehen, dass das jeder tut. Früher oder später wird das Standard sein und das kann nicht bestraft werden, dadurch, dass man als konspirativ betrachtet wird, nur weil man seine Platten oder Mehls verschlüsselt.
Wir schalten mal gleich weiter. Wir schalten mal zu Thomas, der nämlich eine Frage hat zu, ich glaube, zu Beschlagnahm Festplatten. Andi, hoffe, wir haben deins erstmal erklärt.
Ganz toll, ich wünsche euch einen schönen Abend.
Hallo, nach Saarbrücken. Guten Abend, Thomas. Grüße dich. Wir waren gerade beim Thema Festplatten. Ich glaube, da bist du genau in der Mitte.
Ja, vielleicht, ich weiß nicht. Meine Frage, meine Anerkundung ist eher daher...
Sag mal, telefonierst du aus einer Blechdose?
Nein, nicht direkt.
Na geht so.
Haben wir uns früher auch gebastelt, aus zwei Blechdosen.
Ja, mit einer Strippe in der Mitte. Mach mal weiter, es geht schon.
Mein Ding geht es eher dahin, wie ist denn das mit der Beweiskraft bei der ganzen Sache. Weil bei dem Trojaner, da haben wir schon ein bisschen das Problem, dass da kann er jemand anders manipulieren. Wir hatten es ja gerade eben damit, dass da jemand anderes durch den Trojaner reinkommt. Und das Programm an sich, es arbeitet ja auch heimlich, da kann ja hinterher kein Mensch sehen, was passiert da jetzt, was wird da genau geschlagen haben. Es gibt auch so ein bisschen das Problem, man kann ja auch nicht genau jetzt trennen, was ist jetzt privat und was darf nicht gelesen werden und was gehört jetzt mit dazu. Und vielleicht auch noch kurz, das wäre vielleicht auch noch ein Punkt, wo man vielleicht noch ansetzen könnte. Viele jetzt meinen, okay, der Schweizer, der bastelt sich jetzt da noch irgendwelche Gefahrenlagen und dann setzt man den Trojaner ein, dass man vielleicht da ansetzt und sagt, okay, wir setzen vielleicht so eine hohe Hürde für Beweiskraft da ein, für so Sachen, die jetzt aus dem Bundestrojaner da ausspringen, dass es hinterher im Prinzip eigentlich nutzlos ist, weil es überhaupt nicht mehr einsetzbar ist.
Also was wir halt unterscheiden müssen ist, die reden da momentan nicht von Ansatz des Trojaners zur Beweissicherung im Strafverfahren, sondern zur Gefahrenabwehr. Das heißt also, was da immer wieder betont wird und darum ging das Urteil heute auch, ist tatsächlich präventives Handeln. Also sprich, irgendjemand wird verdächtigt irgendwie Terrorist zu sein, begründet in diesem Fall und so weiter und so fort mit hohen Schranken. Und man will gucken, dass man diesen Anschlag, den der plant, verhindert bekommt. So das ist halt so die Argumentation, die die bringen. Dann werden sie es einsetzen. Zum Thema Beweiskraft habe ich bisher in der Urteilsbegründung tatsächlich nichts gefunden. Also das ist tatsächlich weiterhin offen. Keine Ahnung, also bleibt tatsächlich abzuwarten, was da passiert.
Für den präventiven Bereich ist das schlicht nicht relevant.
Das ist irrelevant, genau. Was jetzt die Beweiskraft von beschlagnahmten Daten auf normalen Festplatten betrifft, ist es so, dass es eigentlich einen Prozess gibt, in dem sichergestellt wird, dass zum Beispiel nicht mit der Festplatte, die aus dem Rechner ausgebaut wurde, gearbeitet wird, sondern auf einer Kopie dieser Platte, die eigentlich die Platte weggeschlossen wird. Und du halt im Zweifel im Strafverfahren das Recht hast vergleichen zu lassen, ob tatsächlich die Kopie identisch ist mit dem, was bei dir beschlagnahmt wurde, usw. Es gibt da eigentlich eine Reihe von Regularien. Es ist aber tatsächlich so, dass die in der Praxis extrem schlampig gehandhabt werden. Es gibt immer wieder Fälle, wo Rechtsanwälte finden, dass zum Beispiel die Daten, die dann zurückkommen mit den Festplatten aus der Asservatenkammer, nicht mit denen aus dem Backup übereinstimmen, dass da teilweise Software installiert wird und dergleichen Dinge mehr. Und bis hin dazu, dass tatsächlich diese Festplattenauswertung von Privatfirmen vorgenommen wird, also gerade in den Fällen von Ohrheberrechtsverletzungen, wo dann auch sehr fragwürdig ist, wie qualifiziert die da arbeiten. Also es gibt eigentlich tatsächlich Vorschriften und Prozesse dafür, die sicherstellen sollen, dass halt nur genau diese Daten verwendet werden. Aber in der Realität sieht es häufig in der Praxis sehr anders aus. Also da muss man dann halt tatsächlich, wenn man davon betroffen ist, empfiehlt sich ein Anwalt zu suchen, der das schon mal durch hat und damit Erfahrungen hat. Und hat da auch genau hinzugucken. Also den Beweiserhebungen, die da aus den Strafverfolgungsbehörden kommen, gerade im digitalen Bereich, kann man da nicht bedingungslos trauen.
Geklärt, Thomas?
Jetzt vielleicht noch irgendwie einen Punkt zu dieser Sache, was das Grundrecht uns jetzt noch bringt irgendwie. Was ich noch wichtig fand, ist, dass wir diesen Bereich der Privatsphäre noch sehr viel weiter ausgedehnt hatten. Vorher hatte man irgendwie so das Gefühl, dass Laptops und mobile Geräte, die sind sobald aus dem Haus im Freibild, und auch E-Mails und so, die auf dem IMAP-Server liegen. Und da hat das Bundesverfassungsgericht eigentlich recht deutlich gesagt, dass es eigentlich auch alles irgendwie schutzbedürftig ist.
Ja klar, es geht nicht nur tatsächlich um die Festplatte, sondern sie haben wirklich mehr erwähnt. Etwa eben die Passwörter, die Caches, die Daten. Also man hat eigentlich einen neuen Bereich des virtuellen Lebens, der mitgeschützt ist. Da hast du dann schon Kopf getroffen. Ich denke auch, das wird sicherlich erst in 5 oder 10 Jahren, wenn man überblicken kann, wie wichtig dieses neue Grundrecht für uns ist.
Da wir gerade im juristischen Thema sind, Thomas, hat er ja was zur Beweiskraft von Beschlagnahmen Festplatten. Vielleicht kann Jakob noch etwas dazu beitragen, weil der möchte nämlich gerne noch was wissen zum Richtervorbehalt. Thomas, dir vielen Dank für den Anruf und einen schönen Abend. Tschüss. Namens Jakob.
Hallo.
Mach mal deine Frage so, dass auch ich die verstehe. Weil auf dem Zeichnen im Monitor verstehe ich es gerade nicht.
Ja, ich wollte eigentlich relativ wenig fragen. Ich wollte eigentlich nur ein paar Anmerkungen. Zum Richtervorbehalt war mein Eindruck, als ich das heute gelesen habe, dass es eben nicht nur eine relativ hohe Hürde ist, sondern dass es wirklich eine Weiterentwicklung des Richtervorbehalts ist. Also mehr oder weniger Richtervorbehalt 2.0. Einfach weil der Richter ja wirklich begründen muss, was wir ja vorhin auch schon gehört haben.
Dass es nicht nur in Formularen abzustempeln geht. Genau.
Und ich denke, das ist sehr wichtig, weil ich glaube, es gibt eine wissenschaftliche Untersuchung zur Telekonditionsüberwachung, wo einfach ganz klar zu sehen war, dass dieser Richtervorbehalt in dieser Form, wie er bisher gehandhabt wurde, überhaupt nichts gebracht hat.
Das war Max-Planck-Institut für Strafrecht, wer das nachlesen möchte.
Ja, genau.
Das ist natürlich richtig. Aber ich habe dir den Gedanken selber auch erhabt, als ich in K2 saß und von der eingehenden Prüfung durch den Richter gesprochen wurde. Aber man muss wohl sagen, dass man hier nicht jeden Richtervorbehalt mit einem anderen vergleichen kann. Und er hängt auch sehr davon ab, was für eine Art von schwerwiegendem Eingriff wir haben. Man darf wahrscheinlich nicht vergleichen eine Hausdurchsuchung, die ja auch von einem Richter entschieden wird, und eben sowas wie einen großen Lauschangriff oder die Online-Durchsuchung. Ich denke, dass es das heute schon gibt, diese richterliche Prüfung mit eingehender Begründung. Ich glaube, das ist nicht so neu. Aber nun sind wir auch keine Juristen. Das ist sicherlich eine Frage, die ja auch im juristischen Schriftdruck jetzt debattiert wird. Man muss sich überlegen, was nach so einem Urteil kommt. Dann streiten die sich da monatelang in den Zeitschriften. Auf jeden Fall ist es sicherlich eine Menge interessante Sachen zu lesen. Aber meiner Meinung nach ist das nicht wirklich neu.
Ja, ich hab auch allgemein noch was zu dem BKA-Gesetz zu sagen eigentlich.
Was er demnächst erst ansteht.
Ja, genau. Das wird jetzt vermutlich ziemlich rasch kommen. Also ich hab das damals, als es ja vom CCC veröffentlicht wurde, mit sehr viel Freude gelesen. Weil ich hab da grad ein Praktikum beim Sächsischen Datenschutzbeauftragten gemacht.
Echt?
Jaja, also Freude, dass ich das für meine Arbeit zur Verfügung gestellt gekriegt hab. Herzlichen Dank nochmal.
Bitte, bitte.
Und wir haben natürlich hier jetzt natürlich hohe Hürden für die Online-Durchsuchung. Ich denke, was wir nicht vergessen dürfen, ist, wir haben diesen Eingriff jetzt. Und dieses BKA-Gesetz baut ja unser BKA immerhin zu einem halben Geheimdienst um, wenn nicht zu einem ganzen. Und ich denke, das sollten wir in der ganzen Geschichte nicht vergessen.
Ja, klar, wir haben auch versucht, das immer zu betonen, dass diese Online-Durchsuchung im gesamten BKA-Gesetzentwurf nur ein kleines Steinchen ist im Puzzle. Das ist wohl ein ganz wichtiger Hinweis.
So, diese Geschichte dieser Artikel 20 des BKA-Gesetzes geht von A bis Y. Und das war schon echt heftig, als wir es damals gehört haben.
Kannst du den vielleicht ganz kurz erläutern? Artikel 20, was steht da drin?
Artikel 20 regelt die Befugnisse, die das BKA künftig zusätzlich zu den bisherigen Befugnissen haben wird. Bisher ist das BKA eigentlich eine mehr oder weniger koordinierende Behörde, so was zumindest ursprünglich mal gedacht ist, um die Landeskriminalämter irgendwie zu koordinieren. Und mit diesen Befugnissen in Paragraf 20, eben wie gesagt, 20a bis y, die komplette Palette, gibt es von der Online-Durchsuchung über Telekommunikationsüberwachung, Arbeit mit Imseacatcher, also...
Der Spähangriff, der Zugriff auf private Datensammlungen, da ist echt alles drin.
Da ist das volle Programm drin. Und damit wird aus einer mehr oder weniger koordinierenden Polizeibehörde eine Polizeibehörde, die auch in Wohnungen einbrechen darf, die auch Personen kontrollieren darf. Also wirklich eine Polizeibehörde, die auch wirklich geheimdienstliche Befugnisse letztlich hat. Und das ist was, was wir eigentlich seit dem Zweiten Weltkrieg nicht mehr haben wollten.
Richtig, ja, das ist absolut korrekt. Und man kann es sogar noch drastischer sagen. Wir hatten früher eine Polizei, die hat Verbrecher verfolgt. Heute ist es so, dass es versucht wird, diese BKA so aufzustellen, dass im Prinzip die ganzen Vorfeldermittlungen macht. Also Leute, wo sie eventuell vermuten, die könnten ja mal, und die eigentliche Aufgabe des BKA nämlich Verbrecher zu fangen, tritt da vielmehr in den Hintergrund so weit, dass sie die Geheimdienste in Deutschland schon aufregen, dass ihnen quasi der Aufgabenbereich weggeschnappt wird.
Gut, aber ich glaube, das ist auch ein Thema für eine der nächsten Sendungen, was jetzt an dieser Stelle nicht ausführlich diskutieren lässt. Da werden wir demnächst noch viel Spaß haben.
Einen letzten Punkt, sowas, was vorhin angesprochen wurde, das war der Punkt, ich hab doch nichts zu befürchten und ich hab doch nichts zu verbergen. Das ist immer mein Lieblingsthema. Ich glaub, Frank hat da mal was ganz Gutes zugesagt, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es Frank war, aber ich unterstelle es ihm jetzt mal. Das war die Geschichte. Man hat das gar nicht mehr zu entscheiden. Wenn man sich beispielsweise die 129-Jahre-Verfahren, also die Terrorismusverfahren des letzten Jahres, anschaut, dann sieht man einfach, dass eine bestimmte Menge an Informationen genommen, kategorisiert und interpretiert wird. Und zwar in einer Art und Weise, auf die man als Einziger überhaupt keinen Einfluss mehr hat. Und dann stellt sich die Frage nicht mehr, ob man was zu verbergen hat oder nicht, sondern einfach, ob das eigene Verhalten in einer gewissen Art und Weise interpretierbar ist.
Und wie das Verfassungsgericht heute ja festgestellt hat, ist das Verschlüsseln von Daten Recht, was man privat ausüben darf und nicht mehr ein Verdachtsmoment. Jakob, wir müssen Nachrichten machen, weil ansonsten drehen die uns ihren Hals um. Schönen Abend noch! Und im Chaosradio geht's gleich weiter unter der 0331 70 97 110. Unter anderem mit der Frage von Tobias aus dem Schwarzwald. Werden eigentlich auch Politiker überwacht?
Fritz 15.
Das Fritz-Geburtsdags-Festival am kommenden Samstag in der Arena Berlin Treto ist jetzt leider total ausverkauft. Wer schon Karten hat, hat Glück. Wer noch keine hat, braucht viel Glück. Denn die allerletzten Karten für Fritz 15 gibt's nur noch zu gewinnen. Einfach gut Fritz hören. Das FETZ-Geburtstags-Festival der Arena Berlin Treto. Jetzt also total ausverkauft. für alle, die nicht dabei sein können, wollen oder dürfen, übertragen wir's live im Radio. Mehr Infos fritz.de Kommen am Samstag so ungefähr ab 18 Uhr und dann die ganze lange Nacht auf Fritz. Fritz 15.
Nachrichten mit Philipp Bürger.
Die Bundesregierung hat das Urteil des Bundesverfassungsgerichts zu heimlichen Online-Durchsuchungen begrüßt. Die Richter hätten deutlich gemacht, dass der Staat im Kampf gegen terroristische Bedrohungen nicht darauf verzichten könne, sagte ein Regierungssprecher. Gleichzeitig seien die Grundrechte der Bürger gestärkt worden. Denn die Sicherheitsbehörden dürfen die Computer- und Onlineprofile von Verdächtigen nur dann ausspionieren, wenn Menschenleben oder der Bestand des Staates in großer Gefahr sind. Die Durchsuchung muss von einem Richter angeordnet werden. Die Berliner Polizei hat am Nachmittag einen Club der Rockergruppe Bandidos in Reinickendorf durchsucht. 200 Beamte waren im Einsatz. Ein 23-jähriger Mann wurde laut Polizei festgenommen. Er soll an einem Überfall auf zwei Männer vor einem Vereinshaus der Hells Angels in Charlottenburg beteiligt gewesen sein. Die Täter hätten die Mitglieder des verfeindeten Motorradclubs zum Teil schwer verletzt. In Bremen haben Polizisten bei Ermittlungen ihrer Informanten offenbar mit Drogen geschmiert. Die Staatsanwaltschaft hat sechs verdächtige Beamte auf der Liste. Sie sollen in mehreren Fällen Marihuana und Haschisch zur Belohnung verteilt haben. Ihre Diensträume und Wohnungen wurden durchsucht und Rauschgift sichergestellt. Gebäudereiniger bekommen ab 1. März einen gesetzlichen Mindestlohn. Das teilte das Bundeswetsministerium mit. Man habe sich in der Regierung darauf geeinigt, dass der Mindestlohn wie von den Tarifparteien vereinbart gezahlt werde. Danach beträgt das Mindestgehalt im Westen 8, 15 Euro und im Osten 6, 58 Euro. Im Viertelfinale des DFB-Pokals haben sich Wolfsburg und Hamburg gegenüber gestanden. Gewonnen hat Gastgeber Wolfsburg mit 2 zu 1 nach Verlängerung und steht damit im Halbfinale. Auch das zweite Spiel des Abends wurde nach Verlängerung entschieden. Bayern München besiegte im Lokalderby den ewigen Konkurrenten 1860 München mit 1 zu 0. In der deutschen Eishockeyliga haben die Hannover Scorpions 4 zu 3 nach Verlängerung gegen die Frankfurt Lions gewonnen. Die aktuellen Temperaturen Neuropin und Wittenberge 4 Grad, Potsdam Frankfurt und Angermünde 5 Grad, Cottbus und Berlin 6 Grad. Es ist stark bewölkt draußen, es gibt Regenschauer, es wird recht stürmisch, oder ist es schon? In der Nacht bleibt es dann aber trocken, das Ganze bei Temperaturen zwischen 4 und 1 Grad. Morgen erwarten uns wieder viele Wolken, die sich ab und zu aber auch verziehen. Es soll trocken bleiben, morgen 8 bis 11 Grad wird es maximal. A24 Pritzwald Richtung Berlin Zwischen den Ausfahrten Fährberlin und Kremen liegen Hindernisse und Gegenstände auf der Fahrbahn. Die rechte Spur ist blockiert. Fahrt bitte vorsichtig. Es ist noch nicht bekannt, um was für Gegenstände es sich da handelt. A13 Schönefelder Kreuz Richtung Dresden Zwischen Mittenwalde und Groß-Köris gab es einen Unfall. Bitte fahrt langsam.
Bundestrojaner können sie nicht sein. Die sind nicht so groß.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn im Radio 101, 5, dann Fritz in Eisenhüttenstadt.
Ich hab es schon mal gesehen. Ich hab es schon mal gesehen. Ich hab es schon mal gesehen. Ich hab es schon mal gesehen. Ich hab es schon mal gesehen.
Ich hab es schon mal gesehen.
Ich hab es schon mal gesehen. Ich hab es schon mal gesehen. Ich hab es schon mal gesehen. Ich hab es schon mal gesehen. Mein Name ist Jakob Kranz, wir haben noch knapp 20 Minuten. Wer sich jetzt ins Fadenkreuz genommen, kommen jetzt irgendwelche Behörden daher, von denen ich vielleicht noch nie irgendwas gehört habe, und die fangen jetzt an, in meinem Privatleben rumzuschnüffeln, um am Ende möglicherweise dann etwas herauszuholen, was mich dann schädigen könnte in meiner politischen Laufbahn, oder mich diskreditieren könnte mit meiner Meinung. Und darum geht es ja, da geht es ja nicht nur darum, machen die das auch, sondern nur, könnten sie es tun? Also ich will der Regierung das nicht unterstellen, aber was in den Klappfingern so vorgeht, ist ja das, was eigentlich interessiert in diesem Zeitpunkt. Und das fördert halt eben, das führt dazu, dass dann Leute nicht mehr so aktiv, in der politischen Opposition aktiv werden, wie sie das eigentlich sollten in unserer Demokratie oder wie sie das könnten.
Also ich denke mal, das Beispiel des G8-Gipfels hat sehr deutlich gezeigt, dass es tatsächlich stattfindet. Also dass politische Opposition in Deutschland mit polizeilichen Mitteln unterbunden wird und bestraft wird. Und das ist halt nur eines von vielen Beispielen. Also gerade in den südlichen Bundesländern ist es ja durchaus auch noch durchaus üblich, dass mit polizeilichen Mitteln gegen lokale Aktivisten vorgegangen wird, also Umweltaktivisten zum Beispiel. Oder Leute, die halt zum Beispiel gegen lokale Großprojekte agieren. Das ist halt überhaupt nicht selten, das passiert durchaus täglich so. Also kann man nicht als theoretisch abtun, sondern das ist tatsächlich ein Fakt, ja.
Also man muss vielleicht da auch immer noch mal bedenken, die Technik, die technische Infrastruktur, die gebaut wird, die ist erst mal da. Die Regeln, die diese beschränkt, sind durch Gesetze geregelt. Und die kann man einfach ändern. Wenn man aber jetzt die Technik so hinbaut, dann muss man sich auch überlegen, wer kann vielleicht später diese Regeln machen und ändern. Insofern, man muss auch mal ein bisschen in die Zukunft gucken, wenn man sich solche Überwachungstechniken ansieht, ja.
Genau. Und eben in dem Moment, wo man solche Techniken schafft, oder auch nur darüber überlegt und sie teilweise einsetzt, hat man bereits verloren.
Genau, dann eigentlich ist unser Staat, so wie es die Richter gesagt haben, eigentlich dafür da, gerade in dieser digitalen Welt uns zu schützen, vor allem anderen fiesen Menschen, die so im Netz rumschwirren und unsere, weiß ich nicht, Fische, unsere Passwörter irgendwie auch spionieren wollen und nicht sich selber als dieser Datensammler zu gerieren. Das halten, naja, wahrscheinlich brauchen wir noch eine Weile, bis die Politiker mal erkennen, was den CCC betrifft. So haben wir ja schon seit vielen Jahren gefordert, dass es so eine Art von digitaler Intimsphäre geben soll. Und wir hoffen doch sehr, dass nicht jetzt auch noch die Politiker so lange brauchen, um zu begreifen, dass wir das jetzt haben, dieses Grundrecht.
Stillschweigend werden hier Flüssigkeiten zusammengekriegt.
Stilles Wasser.
Stilles Wasser, deswegen sagst du nicht so viel. Tobias, vielen Dank für deinen Anruf.
Okay, ich sage noch, die Kapitel in München ist toll.
So, und der nächste ist Fortnull, nee, wie heißt du?
FTnull, hallo.
FTnull, Narbent.
Genau, ich komme aus NRW und erstmal herzlichen Dank an euch Berliner. Ihr habt da echt gute Arbeit geleistet und den Karren hier aus dem Dreck gezogen.
Ja, wenn ihr das nicht auf die Reihe kriegt, wa?
Ja, das ist irgendwie so eine Sache.
Die Pressearbeit in Berlin ist echt viel besser. Was ich eigentlich nur ganz kurz anmerken wollte, weil bestimmt noch ganz viele andere Leute da fragen wollen, mir sind zwei Absätze aufgefallen und zwar zum einen irgendwie Absatz 223. Da ist was zur Beweiskraft von so abgeschnäuchelten Daten gesagt. Ich glaube aber, das ist irgendwie als Antwort auf eine der Einsprüche gedacht.
Na, es geht ja immer nur um die Kläger und was sie eigentlich vorgebracht haben. Aber du hast da schon den richtigen Abschnitt erwischt.
Da ist halt kurz gesagt, dass die erhobenen Daten, die man mit so einem Bundestrojaner hat abgeschnäuchelt hat, dass die eigentlich keinen Beweis wert haben, weil man keine exklusive Kontrolle über den Rechner hatte. Das fand ich interessant.
Na ja, sag aber die ganze Wahrheit. Was steht da nämlich eigentlich? Nämlich, dass das keine Rolle spielt, da die an Verfassungsschutzbehörden geht.
Genau.
Und die haben manchmal die Informationinteresse, ohne dass man überhaupt die vor Gerichtsfest haben muss.
Genau, es geht ja dann um die Information und nicht da, dass das irgendwie als Gerichtsfestbeweise ist. Das andere, was mir aufgefallen ist, ist Absatz 183. Das ist doch eigentlich die absolute Ohrfeige gegen die Vorratsdags-Speicherung, wenn ich das richtig gelesen hab.
Genau, also 183, 184.
Genau, das haben wir genau so interpretiert.
Okay, super, dann sehe ich das richtig. Das wollte ich eigentlich auch nur sagen. Und das mit den Beweisen, das war nur, weil Frank vorhin sagte, dass er dazu beweisen eigentlich nichts in der Urteilgründung gefunden hat und nicht einfach mal nach Beweisen gedacht hat.
Ja, es ist nicht so, dass sie völlig nachlesen wollen. Aber es gibt auch www.bundesverfassungsgericht.de gibt es die Urteil- und die Begründung auch für alle zum Klicken, sodass er wüsste, über welche Artikel wir hier reden.
Danke, Herr Geiss.
Es ist so, dass sie dann live, also der Gerichtspräsident Papier, nicht das komplette Urteil verliest, sondern Teile weglässt und in der mündlichen Urteilsbegründung taucht es so nicht auf.
Ist das beabsichtigt? Ist das Zufall?
Ja, das würde einfach zu lange dauern. Es ist ja so schon etwa anderthalb Stunden, dass also da verlesen wird.
Nee, aber dass da bestimmte Passagen nicht verlesen werden.
Nein, er verweist dann auf die schriftliche Begründung.
Genau, also die mündliche Urteilsbegründung ist in der Regel auch noch mal ein bisschen aufgelockert, also zu sagen...
Klar, gestigen Mimik sind ja auch dabei.
Also und er verweist noch mal auf die, sozusagen aus Sicht des Gerichts, wichtigen Punkte in dem Urteil.
Und er guckt in die richtige Richtung.
Genau, also der Papier, das ist halt toll. Der sitzt halt da vorne und schwenkt halt seinen belehrenden Zeigefinger und guckt halt über genau die Leute an, die er meint.
Das ist großartig. Wer hätte gedacht, dass eine Sitzung vom Bundesverfassungsgericht so amüsant sein kann?
Das kam leider bei Phoenix nicht ganz so rüber, weil man ihn immer nur von vorne gesehen hat.
Und bei Phoenix haben sie leider um die Ausnahmen dieses Gesetzes, also um die Ausnahmen dieser Ermächtigungen quasi ging, da haben sie leider genau abgeblendet mit einem völlig uninteressanten Experten befragt.
Das hat man leider nicht mitbekommen.
Ich weiß nicht, vielleicht gibt es später noch mal eine andere Aufzeichnung von. Aber gut, das war es von mir eigentlich schon wieder.
Bitte.
Hannes hat noch einen höchst interessanten Beitrag zur Diskussion. Name Hannes. Du rufst an aus Ilmenau.
Genau, in Thüringen.
In Thüringen. Wie kriegst du da Fritz?
Ja, über das Internet.
Ey, du bist auch einer der wenige, die eine grandiose Telefonleitung haben.
Ja, sogar über OMTS. Man höre einen Staunen.
Wow, also nicht jemand, der mit einer Blechdose telefoniert.
Nee.
Okay, ehe wir jetzt weiterplänkeln, wir haben nicht mehr viel Zeit. Schieß los.
Genau, zum Schluss. Ich wollte noch mal wissen, und zwar, das Problem der Kriminalität hat jetzt ja irgendwie nicht nur Deutschland. Und deswegen würde mich interessieren, wie reagieren jetzt die anderen EU-Länder darauf? Oder haben die vielleicht schon irgendwelche Gesetze diesbezüglich?
Also gibt es in den anderen europäischen Staaten sowas wie die Online-Durchsuchung, Bundesverfassungsgericht, was hier gerade…
Ja, es gibt es tatsächlich. Es gibt einige Europäische, die diese Ermächtigung für ihre Polizeien oder für ihre Geheimdienste haben, aber eine Minderheit. Ich habe es zum Beispiel bei Zypern gelesen. Also die größeren Länder, die einen entscheidenderen Einfluss haben, in Brüssel, die sind bisher alle noch so im Streit. Es gibt aber durchaus in den anderen Ländern auch diesen politischen Streit.
Also insofern setzt Deutschland da schon starker Akzent. Also wenn man vergleicht zum Beispiel mit Großbritannien, wo es den sogenannten RIP Act gibt, wo dich die Polizei zwingen kann, und zwar dadurch, dass sie sich in den Knast stecken, wenn du dein Passwort vergessen hast, für die Festplattenverschlüsselung sind wir hier tatsächlich wieder mal doch deutlich weiter vorne. Also hat Deutschland mit diesem Urteil doch eine Führungsposition eingenommen, und zwar diesmal ausnahmsweise ein positives.
Und da schmort man so lange im Bau, bis einem wieder einfällt, es ist Erdbeersaft 23.
So ist es. Man kann sich halt überlegen, ob die maximale Länge, die man im Bau schmoren kann, im Verhältnis zu der maximalen Länge, die man wegen der Daten auf der Platte im Bau schmoren kann, steht.
Also sie kann ja mal die Länder nennen, wenn es jetzt sehr von Interesse ist. Das wäre schon interessant zu erfahren. Ja, das ist nämlich Zypern, Lettland, Spanien und Rumänien. Da haben wir richtig so eine große Demokratie.
Also nichts, wo man eh hin auswandern wollte.
Spanien?
Ach na ja.
Na ja, wird es sich ja einfach mal interessant zu wissen, wie die das Hand haben. Ich meine, die wollen ja vielleicht auch wissen, was ihre Leute im Internet machen oder auf ihren Rechnern rumfliegen haben, die immer mit ähnlichen Problemen zu kennen, zu kämpfen. Jetzt zum Beispiel auch Spanien oder Großbritannien, die ja nun auch in der Vergangenheit entsprechend mit diesen Anschlägen zu tun hatten.
Das fällt mir ein. Österreich natürlich auch. Die haben ja jüngst diesen Bundestrojaner auch beschlossen. Es ist natürlich klar, dass es internationalen Trend ist. Einer hat die Idee und die Innenminister reden ja auch miteinander. Es wird wohl sehr schwer als Idee einzudämmen sein. Wir werden hier doch in Deutschland Glück haben, dass wir diese Online-Übersuchung mit so hohen Schranken haben. Da können wir uns glücklich schätzen.
Danke Hannes. Das war's. Und am Telefon ist Remo, Name Remo. Du hast ziemlich lange warten müssen. Ich hoffe, da ist auch dein Verständnis, weil hier ist ja Hölle los gerade.
Ja, ist nicht das Problem. Für mich ist eigentlich die Frage, ob man unbedingt die Terroristen damit abfangen kann, die Osama bin Laden, die sich da wahrscheinlich eher über die Nachrichten über irgendwelche Läufer rüber schicken anstatt übers Internet. Ja genau, Brieftauben oder einfach mal... Oder so, weil es ähnlich ist, oder einfach, indem man einfach mal jemanden schickt, der sagt, hier, zu dir muss die Nachricht und dann bringen die ihm das hin.
Also wenn ich dich richtig verstehe, zielt es darauf ab, ob dieses ganze System der Online-Überwachung, Bundestrojaner überhaupt dorthin geht, wo es eigentlich hin soll.
Also ich glaube mal eher, dass man eher auf diesen Pelophilenring abgesehen hat, dass man die Leute damit kaschen kann.
Filesharing.
Das ist wahrscheinlich wesentlich höher, als wenn man irgendwo versucht, da irgendwie die Alkei dazu attakieren. Das wird man wohl wahrscheinlich weniger schaffen.
Aber es sind ja zwei Bereiche. Betroffen ist ja unter anderem in diesem Verfassungsschutzgesetz auch die Frage, ob man online etwa Foren durchsuchen kann. Also die eigentliche Online-Durchsuchung. Also nicht die Durchsuchung der Festplatte, sondern des Netzes. Und da ist es durchaus so, dass das erlaubt ist. Das hat auch das Verfassungsschutzgesetz heute nochmal betont. Und wenn du zum Beispiel so einen Pelophilenring ausheben willst, dann solltest du gucken, wie sie sich dort in den Foren austauschen. Das ist weiterhin erlaubt. Es geht ja um die Ausspielen mit der Festplatte.
Um die digitale Privatsphäre, wie es heute von dir geht.
Aber letztendlich, diese Videos, die schicken sich ja Pelophile teilweise auch. Neuerdings ja nur noch übers Internet hin und her. Die schicken das ja nicht mehr mit der Post. Die Kommunikation ja auch.
Die kann abgehört werden, natürlich.
Das hätte man auch schon vorher machen können. Das hätte man früher auch schon geschafft mit den entsprechenden Gesetzen. Die Sache ist die, ich glaube, man schiebt hier den Terrorismus vor, um andere Sachen wesentlich einfacher machen zu können.
Also davon sind wir ausgegangen bei der Beurteilung der Initialgesetzentwürfe, dass halt der Terrorismus da wieder mal nur die Begründung ist. Dem hat das Bundesverfassungsgericht nun halt ein Riegel vorgeschoben. Sie haben halt gesagt, dass es tatsächlich um Leib und Leben beziehungsweise über Leben des Staates gehen muss. Und deswegen ist sozusagen die Diskussion an der Stelle halt beendet.
Gut, aber die andere Frage ist, wie das dann entsprechend in der Praxis umgesetzt wird.
Das werden wir dann sehen, ja.
Das ist ziemlich, naja, hoffen wir mal, dass dieses Gesetz sinnvoll angewendet wird. Aber viele Sachen werden ja leider nicht sinnvoll angewendet.
Und das Schlusswort für heute, ich weiß, wir warten ganz viele Leute in der Leitung, wir schaffen es einfach, stichtend ergreifend nicht mehr. Schlusswort für heute kriegt Axel, Name, Axel.
Hallo, Name Konstanze, Name den Rest. Namen habe ich eh alle, war ich wieder vergessen.
Wir hatten vorhin das Thema Festplatten, die zu untersuchen sind. Und da das Amt selber nicht schafft, gehen die zu externen Firmen. Da kannst du sicherlich auch ein Lied davon singen.
Ich habe aber noch ein viel größeres Problem. Es ist wunderschön, dass wir jetzt richtig große Hürden intern aufgebaut haben, die verhindern sollen. Dass irgendjemand etwas tut auf dem privaten Rechner, was er nicht. Damit ist aber sozusagen die allgemeine Hürde Relativheit angehoben. Und es kommen andere Ideen meiner Ansicht nach in Betracht, über die man vorher wahrscheinlich gar nicht nachgedacht hat. Wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel auf die Idee käme, also ganz bitterböse gesagt als Staat, ich beschäftige gar nicht mehr den Bundesnachrichtendienst damit, sondern ich suche mir eine ausländische Firma, die richtig gut ist, die im internationalen Sicherheitsbereich wirklich auf Draht ist, die das auch können. Dann gilt für die das deutsche Gesetz sowieso nicht. Wir machen das im Rahmen eines Vertrages, der in einer Größe ist, der in Deutschland nicht nachgefragt werden muss, also mit vielen kleinen Verträgen. Und lassen den dann das einfach tun, an bestimmten Stellen.
Kritiker behaupten, das passiert bereits. Es ist tatsächlich so, dass dieses Überbandespielen im geheimdienstlichen Bereich total üblich ist. Also dass sich die Geheimdienste jeweils aushelfen, wenn sie im nationalen Gesetzesbereich nicht mehr weiterkommen.
Das sind keine Geheimdienste mehr, sondern es geht darum, dass sich private Leute, private Firmen, und die stehen völlig außerhalb jeden Gesetzes.
Also ich meine, es ist so, dass irgendwie, zum Beispiel bei der CIA, es ist bekannt, dass die mittlerweile komplette Operationen von privaten Dienstlästern durchführen lassen. Und da halt dann natürlich sehr viel wenig wird.
Für die gibt es dann gar nichts mehr. Die dürfen dann im Endeffekt alles. Und deshalb habe ich das Gefühl, wir haben zwar jetzt die Schmerzschwelle sehr hoch gesetzt, aber da wir eventuell die Reitschwelle genau so was zu machen, ist dann eher erreicht. Natürlich ist es, wenn das herauskommt, ein riesen Skandal. Aber dann verkeiligt irgendwo die Mittel.
Da sind wir dann halt irgendwie im Bereich der Überwachung der Geheimdienste, was halt ein abendführendes Thema ist.
Ja, das ist ja nochmal ein wirklich großes Problem, weil die Kontrollgremien, die wir haben in Deutschland, also zum Beispiel die parlamentarische Kontrollgremium, sagen viele Mitglieder davon, dass sie ohne nichts zu kontrollieren haben, ist es aber nochmal ein ganz anderes Feld. Es ist schon klar, dass du natürlich mit deinem Denken da sicherlich in die richtige Richtung denkst. Und die jüngsten Veröffentlichungen, die es so gibt an Büchern darüber, egal ob bei uns oder in den USA, deuten auch in die Richtung. Aber das ist halt nochmal ein anderes Feld.
Aber trotz alledem ist der, und deswegen freut mich auch, dass Axel hier das Schlusswort hat, ist dieser Einwand am Ende vom heutigen Chaosradio natürlich absolut berechtigt. Ehe wir jetzt alle uns freudig um die Arme fallen und sagen, hey super, hat doch funktioniert, sollte man vielleicht nicht die wirkliche Realität aus den Augen lassen.
Es gibt noch viel zu tun.
Ja, weil wir müssen dieses Grundrecht auch anwenden, und zwar wir alle. Wenn wir es nicht benutzen und tatsächlich auch mal unsere Festplatten verschlüsseln, unsere E-Mails verschlüsseln, dann wird es ins Leere laufen. Wir müssen als gerade die jüngere Generation auch dahinter stehen. Die Richter haben uns halt geschenkt und wir müssen Geschenk aber auch annehmen.
Nicht nur verschlüsseln, sondern einfach auch mit den eigenen Daten viel bewusster umgehen und schauen, dass man es halt nicht in StudiVZ, genau die Daten, die man sonst auf seiner Festplatte geschützt haben möchte, noch mal ein Klartext hinschreibt.
Ja, schön.
Axel, vielen Dank, gute Besserung, du klingst erkältet.
Ja, reden wir nicht drüber.
Schönen Abend. Das war eine hervorragende Sendung Chaosradio 132. So viele Anrufer hatten wir lange nicht, mir klingeln die Ohren. Und wenn wir jetzt, wir könnten locker noch weitermachen, dann müsste Maxwell Smart aber hier ausflippen, weil wir ihm sonst seinen Night-Flight-Klauen, der in wenigen Minuten beginnt, mit handausgegrabenen Beats und von Mutti zusammengestrickten Breaks und was auch sonst er immer an seiner Kiste dabei hat. Chaosradio.ccc.de ist die Website, auf der ihr nachgucken könnt, was in dieser Sendung und beim CCC passiert unter anderem. Da könnt ihr gucken, wo die Podcasts zu finden sind, könnt euch Chaosradio Express ziehen und alle sonstige Dinge machen. Das war Chaosradio für heute. Wir sagen vielen Dank, verabschieden uns und hören uns spätestens am letzten Mittwoch im März wieder. Das waren Constanze, Frank, Erdgeist und Jakob.